cet automne on va se pencher sur le
grand thème du territoire agricole et on
commence aujourd'hui en parlant de
morcellement du territoire est-ce que
c'est la solution pour faciliter l'accès
à la terre pour la relève voici d'abord
deux exemples dans deux régions
différentes au prises avec un même
problème des terres qui sont à la fois
rares et chères
[Musique]
à l'ouest de la ville de Québec
Saint-Augustin et de démarre connaît un
printemps tardif
Hubert Steven Chabot peut enfin mettre
en terre les premiers plans les plantes
maraîchères couvrent une petite surface
qu'il vend en panier de famille
cette année je vais aller récolter à peu
près une trentaine de légumes différents
des tomates des courges des brocolis
je vais avoir 12 variétés de piments
forts
mais la terre agricole qui fait vivre
uber ne lui appartient pas je suis en
location
une fois qu'on élimine toutes les
bâtiments chemins et autres on parle d'à
peu près point 5.6 hectares cultivé
être en location est un frein à son
expansion
son projet est la production mixte de
culture annuelle et pérenne comme les
arbres à noix
implanter des végétaux alors que le bail
de location peut prendre fin
soudainement est exclu
j'ai 30 ans le gros de l'argent que
j'avais je l'ai mis sur ma production
parce que quand je commence à produire
j'ai pas plus de 100000 dollars
il voudrait acheter et autour de Québec
des petites terres de moins de 4
hectares comme ils cherchent il y en a
beaucoup des milliers de petites
surfaces mais très chers
[Musique]
on veut aider la relève agricole puis à
Mamie regarde les prix qui se vendent
sur le marché immobilier où ils sont
implémentés
le montant des transactions dans sa
région dépasse largement ce qu'il avait
prévu dans son plan d'affaires
à Saint-Augustin il y a des tas qui se
sont vendus à 25000 dollars lecteurs on
est au double du seuil de rentabilité
pour une grande culture définitivement
les temps agricoles qui sont situés plus
près des centres urbains ont
effectivement font face à une demande
plus élevée et donc plus d'acheteurs
potentiel et lorsque plus d'acheteurs
potentiels effectivement ça pousse les
prix à la hausse
[Musique]
on décembre 2021 dans le but de morceler
plus facilement c'est-à-dire subdiviser
des lots afin de rendre disponible de
petites surfaces le gouvernement du
Québec a modifié la Loi sur la
protection du territoire et des
activités agricoles pour ainsi tenir
compte des nouveaux modèles de
production
[Musique]
ce que le projet de loi est venu dire au
commissaire
c'est que vous devez dans tous les cas
analysez à la fois la proche
territoriale et l'approche économique et
vous devez considérer la démonstration
d'un projet agricole lorsque cette
démonstration là vous avez fait et
évaluer dans le cas dans ce cas-là si ce
projet-là est viable du point de vue des
comme ça c'est la nouveauté au niveau du
harcèlement
dorénavant la cpdaq à l'obligation
d'accorder plus d'importance à la
viabilité économique du projet agricole
c'est à l'intention du législateur que
les choses changent c'est ce qu'on a
compris
malgré tout la modification de la loi
est loin de faire l'unanimité Hubert
lui-même est ambivalent
personnellement ça peut être une bonne
idée mais ça a l'air de s'ennuyer pour
être une fausse bonne idée plus les
parcelles sont petites plus elle risque
d'être délaissée
[Musique]
en 2017 dans la région de la Capitale
nationale seulement 4% des lots
agricoles de moins de 4 hectares étaient
utilisés par des fermes
au magazine pas une maison pour vivre en
disant que j'ai des revenus hautes en
magazine notre revenu notre emploi on
achète notre revenu belle prairie un
bloc de temps comme celui-ci c'est
possible on est strie à nous carons
rêves depuis 10 ans d'avoir une ferme
pour l'élevage de bisons
cultiva pour pouvoir faire du pâturage
pour mes bisons multiplier les terres
morcelés ne vient que compliqués sa
recherche de terre d'aller couper des
terres ça va venir empêcher des gens
comme moi qui voudrais avoir besoin
d'une grande terre on vient découper le
paysage puis le principal danger relié à
ça c'est que si le projet agricole est
mis en place sur une terre morcelée une
maison qui est bâtie qui s'est revendu à
une personne non agricole on vient de
perdre encore du territoire agricole
pour un particulier et non une
entreprise agricole Anouk
son projet est au point ces animaux
réservés son plan d'affaires est bien
ficelé elle connaît ses limites
financières j'ai évalué environ à 10 000
pièces là que une terre en culture puis
on est à peu près à 3000 pièces locks
dans le Brésil donc c'est ce qu'on
estime qu'on est capable de payer
actuellement dans mon projet mais les
terres sont hors de prix
les exemples les plus d'un million de
dollars sont fréquents
parfois des maisons inhabitées comme
celle-ci jumelée à une terre trop cher
et trop petite pour Anouk
dernièrement j'ai vu aussi des terres à
vendre dont une dernière sur les
internet avec un préalable de 35000
pièces lock donc
elle voit aussi des terres agricoles
abandonnés mais c'est une affaire très
coûteuse
[Musique]
ok il y a du déboisement à faire de la
petite branchère il faut faire un bon
brûlage retourner chaulé pour être
capable de faire remettre en culture
donc il y a beaucoup de travail à mettre
là c'est là que ça devient-il d'être
capable de dire et on paye 10 000 pièces
là que cette terre-là puis en plus on
doit remettre un quelques milliers de
dollars là une fortune pour redonner à
la terre son plein potentiel agronomique
c'est trop cher payé et aucune aide
gouvernementale n'est prévu pour la
remise en culture une terre laissée à
l'état de friche un boisé en zone
agricole
laisser tel quel c'est de l'agriculture
alors au sens de la loi au sens de la
loi
donc c'est pas négatif en soi
pour la zone agricole là où ça peut
poser problème c'est la demande qui
pourrait venir par la suite pour une
exclusion ou une autorisation pour une
activité non agricole
pourtant réclamer depuis des années au
Québec il n'existe aucun inventaire des
hectares en friche et petites superficie
à vendre
selon des agriculteurs et des
spécialistes de la protection du
territoire agricole le ministère de
l'Agriculture aurait le pouvoir et
toutes les raisons de créer cette
inventaire et caractériser ces terres
afin d'optimiser la mise en valeur de la
zone agricole
au cours des cinq dernières années au
Québec 10 000 hectares agricoles ont été
détournés de leur vocation vers d'autres
usages être capable de faire un tour de
réseau de toute la complexité de Michel
Saint-Pierre témoins des changements de
l'agriculture depuis 50 ans sont des
hommes
une terre en région pyrure urbaine c'est
pas un espace en attente de développer
immobilier
l'ancien ou fonctionnaire a vécu
l'adoption de la loi sur la protection
agricole
44 ans plus tard un immense capital de
terres agricoles d'or
47% des terres en zone protégées ne sont
pas en exploitation
à l'origine la loi devait mettre fin à
la spéculation immobilière
aussi durcir le ton un peu puis être
capable d'obliger un usage de ces
terres-là surtout dans les zones qui
sont de très bonnes qualités il faudrait
obliger le propriétaire d'une terre
agricole à la garder en exploitation
autre problème pourra nous elle se
retrouve en compétition avec les très
grands producteurs qui prennent de
l'expansion ils ont la capacité
financière d'acheter les terres elle
n'est pas de taille et une terre
au dépanneur c'est avant souvent au 25
ans ou 30 ans ou moins que ça donc c'est
vraiment difficile à trouver en plus de
ça mais ça c'est pas que la terre est à
vendre il y a pas une pancarte qui mis
au bord du chemin ou très rarement donc
ça va être vendu de bouche à oreille
entre des voisins des gens qui se
connaissent les revenus agricoles tirés
de la ferme sont en hausse les taux
d'intérêt longtemps maintenu très bas
les perspectives de croissance sont
devenues intéressantes
ça crée une hausse de la demande et plus
d'entreprises qui cherchent à développer
certains créneaux ou encore prendre de
l'expansion et de l'autre côté du côté
de l'offre mais l'offre de terre sur le
marché est limité et donc offre limitée
demande forte ça pousse les prix à la
hausse et donc je suis pas surpris de
voir les augmentations qu'on a vu dans
les dernières années
entre 2009 et
2019 la valeur des terres en culture a
augmenté de 227%
en 2021 seulement l'esprit a connu une
hausse de 30%. ça c'est vraiment un des
plus gros freins de trouver une terre
qui est accessible financièrement pour
être capable d'être rentable à long
terme déplorable pour Michel
Saint-Pierre qui se réjouit de la venue
de ces jeunes et de leur nouveau modèle
de ferme des jeunes qui sont souvent pas
en mode relève de ferme ils sont en mode
partir une entreprise partir une PME
agricole donc avec des objectifs de
revenus sur des espaces pour lesquels ce
qui est important c'est 6 enfants et non
pas ce qui capitalise
quatre mois après l'adoption du projet
de loi voulant venir en aide à la relève
le bilan était mitigé
la cpdaq a reçu 24 demandes de
morcellement
12 ont été autorisés parmi elles 5
d'abord refusés ont été acceptés en
appliquant les nouveaux critères de la
loi
cette route c'est un changement majeur
ou pas on va voir la tendance sur le
long terme mais actuellement c'est pas
une révolution il n'y a pas affluence là
depuis l'adoption de des modifications
de la loi on n'a pas senti ça jusqu'à
maintenant
[Musique]
les terres sont un meilleur placement
que bien d'autres actifs financiers
qui serait pressé de vendre ou morcelé
dans ce contexte
purement financier à la chose mais
n'importe laquelle gestionnaire
financier ou en regardant ceci et voir
j'ai un retour plus intéressant et j'ai
une volatilité témoin c'est quasiment le
paradis ici
[Musique]
on respecte plus le contrat qu'on avait
un peu avec la société de produire de
nourrir notre mort
[Musique]